pro actions predicts future behavior
past actions predict future behavior if
a woman is impaired bonding look it up
she's more likely to revert to being a
304 infidelity divorce and if she isn't
bonded to her mate what sense
what sense man is going to willing to
bet she will is willing to bet that she
will make moral and sound decisions
so it's like she's saying like if you're
sleeping around now like then that like
um i think that's really reductionist um
so if you knew me
i was suicidal i tried to kill myself a
couple of times
um and so if you knew me who i was um
even a year ago no no actually not a
year ago year ago was good but two years
ago i was very codependent i was very i
had very low self-worth i had and so to
be like your past actions determine who
you are no you've spoiled about
self-awareness it's all about yeah you
can't say if a guy went to prison three
times for for
attempted battery he might do it again
oh no 100 i understand like you you can
say that you can't say that but to
reduce a woman to be like oh just
because so i was very codependent and so
the men i date now
would be like well based on your history
you want a relationship with me you're
gonna fall in love with me and i'm like
you are very confused i don't want that
at all right now i will because i'm very
different
i'm so i've been i've been single by
choice for a year and a half like that's
not a bad thing it's okay to like fall
in love like a year and a half it's been
a year and a half and i've not yeah yeah
but but i'm i'm saying like
your question if you met a guy that you
really liked and you were considering
him for a relationship
and he told you that he had cheated in
every relationship previous to this
are you saying that would not at all
impact his desirability to you for a
boyfriend no i'm not saying that i'm not
against that's it it's not black and
white it's not one size fits all i will
i will keep saying so i'm going i'm blue
in the face it's not one size fits all
it's really not saying not saying that
it'd be like not saying it's the
deciding factor but like would it not
shift your opinion of him potentially as
a boyfriend or do you think if that
would not impact your view of him at all
no no being being realistic yeah you
would be being a realist yeah and the
same way so you'd understand if a guy
viewed like basically sleeping around a
lot the same way but then we've got yeah
yeah but then we've got
um if you have like 500 days of summer
is one of my favorite films and she says
when you know you know and i've dated a
lot of guys who are like i'm never gonna
be relation i'm never gonna i was like
well you will you will meet someone at
some point in your life it's probably
inevitable that you will meet someone
that you're like i'm gonna settle down i
don't agree with when you know you know
i think that you make a choice
and like that's it like i don't think
most people well yeah
that it's the right choice but i'm
saying i don't think you'll ever know
and i think that's like a lot of like
now fear today and like dating today is
people thinking that they're just gonna
they're just gonna know but all you can
do is make a decision with the
information that you have but then yeah
but then you'll know that like
and even nowadays like people are dating
like what a decade five years three
years before they they decide to get
married do you think those people just
knew if they're dating three
like
i don't think they know it's the one i
don't believe in the one but i think
they know that they especially and so it
that research shows that women will kind
of um
look for that long term men will get to
a point where they're suddenly like
oh [ __ ] i kind of need to settle down
now ergo i'm going to look right if
she's here and she fits in she'll do so
men actually technically end up settling
and they don't know why is that one why
is it settling it's no it's it's they
just made a choice they said okay yeah
i'm looking to like get married in this
time frame this girl fits everything i i
i'm looking for but she doesn't
necessarily fit everything looking
forward that's why because people aren't
perfect
so i don't i don't think it's
really settling if you say okay she
doesn't have everything like it's kind
of like do you know what she'll do yeah
she'll do i think women could be better
but she'll do yeah but i think women
like
probably could you know have a little
bit more he'll do yeah yeah i don't
think that's a bad thing because i'm not
perfect yeah i can't expect the guy dave
to be perfect
and so like
yeah like i just i don't like the word
settling it's not settling yeah i i i
like you agree because especially with
like romance and like novels and like
films and stuff you believe that there's
this idea of the one and i know and it's
like you actually don't you actually
just need to be okay with what is and
what's happening and be like will you
want more probably a lot of people in
relationships and marriages you can ask
someone to be like what do you love
about your partner what do you not love
what do you wish was different like even
i would not date a snorer and that is
and that's uh if you don't have a
driver's license and you snore and
people are like well that's not me
people's fault and i was like i
literally know that i would want to kill
you if both of those things weren't a
thing yeah but if i really loved a guy
then i'd be like well [ __ ] it i don't
care i don't know i say like girls have
all these standards until they met the
guy that makes them not care but then
it's like well do i do i know or am i
like yeah but here's i always say i'd be
the type i swear to god i'd get married
in six months because i feel like there
there's risk there's risk regardless
i'd rather just do it and hope for the
best and if it doesn't i'll get divor
like but like i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go into something
like okay being afraid of divorce
whatever it happens i hope it doesn't
happen to me like do you think you would
be more afraid of divorce if you're a
man
oh yeah i absolutely would yeah
because mine gets screwed over so oh
actually no no i got i got
i'm in this situation i should be afraid
i should be afraid
you should actually yeah you should but
nah i mean i think like again there's
risk with everything like so you think
if you if you're a man you would look at
marriage as openly as you do now
um
probably not probably not i have a
question do you think your dad if he was
in our generation would get married
today yes you think he did yeah he he
wants my brother to get married oh yeah
no i mean my dad my parents are more
like traditional so oh that's like
like i don't know i think there's a lot
of legal issues and problems that like
i'll advocate for for matt like they're
not represented fairly in court like i
don't i don't think that you should be
able to take half a man's income just
because you had a kid together yeah
i think i'll be i think the laws are
only going to change
in
not the next generation next generation
after because a lot of men are saying
they're not going to get married because
of it and i think because women still
want to get married they're going to
start advocating for those laws to
change yeah no probably i think that's
right what are you going to say just
quickly
piggybacking off of that i think a lot
of like yeah you're saying men don't
want to get married women do and there's
a lot
there is a lot of dependency upon like
taking a man's name and like getting a
mortgage all that stuff but i really
want to know how do you feel about like
dad's giving their daughter away
oh i think it's a really cute tradition
i wish i would i tell my dad i was i
tell him he could pick out my husband
all the time he doesn't want to though
he says i've got i'm busy
oh okay
oh
so for me it'd be nice if he's like no
i'm not gonna pick your husband you pick
someone that you think is well that's
kind of what he does he's like because
if it goes wrong you'll blame me
he's like i'm not being in charge of
that i have to meet your dad at some
point if he's ever in london you have to
tell me oh no
and you know i know from that's it my
own bias and my like poor relationship
with my dad i'm like i hate the idea of
belonging to a man and being given to a
man but i know that actually if i had a
good relationship with my dad i'd
probably be in your shoes i'd probably
yeah it's actually really sweet i mean
because you're i think like as women i
mean
we're attracted to shitty traits and we
can't really help it like i'm
freud we have a field day no like we
like [ __ ] we do i mean and i
understand like the science of why it's
like the dark triad traits like the same
trait yeah can you can you define the
dart track because i only discovered
this recently oh god i don't remember it
off the top of my head but it's like
like a guy that's aggressive right like
why do women stay with the men that like
beat them because the same men that like
are aggressive and like beat them can
also beat up someone else so it's the
same trait yeah right a guy
like a guy that's controlling right he
also can control the environment yep
yeah so it's i don't remember all of
them but it's like it's like the same
traits that make a guy like completely
like an awful like partner also make him
a really good one yeah so i have a
question for the ladies on the panel um
if you know that this is what you're
attracted to why do you think so many
women say they just want a nice guy
i don't think they realize that so do
you yeah i was gonna so my next question
was do you think a lot of women are
unaware of what they're actually
attracted to yes yes i really think it
comes from inexperience because at the
end of the day being nice is not enough
it's really not enough it's the bare
minimum it's like breathing it's like i
don't think being nice is actually
admired to be honest like like condition
like unconditional kindness from a man i
think is seen as weakness totally
because well it's because like it's a
guy that doesn't like because a lot of
times this is this is my experience a
lot of times guys will say they're nice
but they're not they're not actually
nice
they're not nice they're afraid to stand
up for themselves and they're they like
we don't like guys that put us on a
pedestal like why do we think we like
like guys that make fun of us a little
bit yeah because you're treating us like
we're human so if we say something dumb
and you call it like
you know yeah or they think they're nice
because they're like well i'm not raping
someone i'm not beating you up ergo i'm
nice and i'm like
i've never heard a guy say that
we have never heard a guy say that
a personal experience but yeah no i
think everyone guys say they're nice
they're like i've given her everything i
i take her here i do this i do this i
think i think it's a lot of guys that go
above and beyond for women but women
don't respect guys that give them
everything without making them earn it
but then we get in cell culture and so
it's like men who are like i'm xyz it's
like you're not though you're not as
good as you think you are you are the
best being nice is the best well i think
incels are kind of a result of women not
settling
and like like women saying i'd rather be
alone than have to settle instead of
like i don't know and then this goes
back to i actually think men are not i
actually think and this is i actually
think as much as i'm for female
empowerment and like i actually think
men end up settling more
and i think men actually end up
disappointing themselves more being like
if you asked a man write down your
perfect woman on paper and let's compare
it to the woman that you ended up with
i think that yeah i think a lot more
women are actually like i'd rather be
alone than settle but then it's like you
actually could be alone forever if
you're not willing to settle if you're
not well but you can but you can't you
can but then you'll be homeless yeah
yeah most women you need 2.5 million to
retire
um
i in regards to men settling i think
that i think men just don't have a lot
on their list
for women i think they're just a one
honestly i think
i think the majority of men in terms of
long term just want a woman who's warm
kind and peaceful
and as if she's that with a low body
count
well yeah ideally i think ideally but i
think even if she i think that's i think
that is a preference
but i think i think the difference is
like
men don't have a lot of
conditional points whereas i think a lot
of women have conditionals so a lot of
women will make their preference as part
of the condition
you know so she might okay a guy has to
be six foot if he's not six foot i'm not
gonna entertain him whereas a guy might
be like okay i'd rather she's
four inches shorter than me but she's
the same height i can live with that i